this season was so much fun it was wild
crazy we had vulva cupcakes amy
we did let's first start with eric and
adam eric cheated on adam then broke up
with adam
savage i know such a savage move for you
shootie how did you feel about how
things played out there
um actually pretty good
i think yeah i did i did i know a lot of
people are supporting eric and adam but
i guess
um i think i thought it was really good
because i felt like eric made the
decision for himself and and made the
decision towards his
his own happiness i think that's what
that was i think
throughout the relationship we've seen
eric make a lot of space for
for adam and have to be very like
patient for adam and kind of be where ed
for adam is
like mentally and emotionally
emotionally in terms of their
relationship and i think in season three
we see the friction between them because
they're at such different places in
terms of their
their sexual discovery and their journey
and there's like they've got this real
connection with each other and
understanding of each other and they
have such i guess like complex
backstories as to why they found each
other and yet even though they found
each other it doesn't negate the fact
that they're in different places and
they've got to try and figure that out
and i think eric has has been on his
journey of like people pleasing and i
think made a lot of space for adam and
when he went out to nigeria
i think he learned that he means he
needs a lot of space to grow because
there's a lot of elements to him he's
nigerian he's black he's gay he's
religious he needs space to grow and he
needs space to be his full authentic
self and i think him coming back and
realizing that with adam i think it's a
great decision for the pair of them
because i think adam also needs to grow
individually as well so i was happy with
it
is is there hope for a reconciliation do
you think
perhaps you never know
you never know we're more deal there's
always a question mark over everything
what what about with oba in nigeria i
mean like you said sparks flew there
could we see more of him in season four
who i mean who knows who
who knows i don't know i actually have
no idea how to even know if we're doing
a season four but i think that like
fingers crossed i think sparks
definitely flew between the pair of them
and when
when eric said to adam on the bridge
like the kiss was something like it was
something it was so something
so i think what i think also what what
what caused the sparks was um
the fact that oba is able to
completely understand the shoes that
eric is walking in um he understands all
the intersections that he sits in and
eric for the first time
imagine like for eric felt for the first
time in a country where it's completely
illegal to be his full self that is
where he felt his full self and so i
think that spoke volumes for him in
terms of the relationship that he has
back home and so who knows maybe
hopefully oba
helps him on that journey a little more
see him again yeah great amy let's talk
amy for a little bit quite the journey
for her this season like i mentioned i
did love the vulva cupcakes but it was
also kind of an emotional journey for
her and then her friendship with maeve
was was pretty rocky until the end how
did you feel about
her her journey this season
i absolutely love her journey this
season i think she's at such an
interesting point in her life where
she's kind of like still trying to hold
on to old amy as she calls it but very
much like
really coming into this new
kind of bigger amy and it's that kind of
like tug of war was so interesting to
play and i think that the the conflict
with maeve
is really kind of it causes a huge like
tectonic shift and it is a catalyst for
a lot of other things to open up and for
a lot of things to change because it's
probably like one of her biggest fears
you know she says i lied to people
because i don't like upsetting them and
that's just the way i've always been and
it's actually
it's that discovery of
no
maeve's right i am a people pleaser when
amy then goes to therapy she's really
really ready
to to kind of let the therapy really
work on her because she's in this open
vulnerable place and she's kind of
faced her fear which is you know
conflict and she's such a she's always
wanted people to like her so much and
actually the person that she likes the
most and the person that likes her the
most in the world maeve
at that point in time doesn't really
like her and so she all of a sudden is
there like okay who am i now and it's
only through kind of the other kind of
aspects of her life that the opening up
and facing her fears in different areas
that she kind of
reaches the real core
of what's going on for her which is she
still kind of thinks it's her fault
that what happened on the bus and that's
why you know she's been scared of her
own body because she thinks in some way
it was her body that caused that to
happen and it was her smile and when
jean then finally says it's got nothing
to do with your smile or anything it's
all about him she can finally hear it so
i think it's it's such a kind of amazing
journey because she is she's kind of
like if she's been kind of a bit of a
you know sweep under the carpet la la la
kind of person there's a kind of like
the demons following you there but
you're just kind of ignoring it season
three at the start she's kind of like
got one eye on it but she's still kind
of looking away and then right near the
end she fully looks it in the eyes and
she's like no longer afraid she does at
the end break up with steve
where do you think we could potentially
see amy if we get a season for what
would you like to explore yeah i think
it's sad because steve and amy were so
amazing in so many ways and they had a
really lovely healthy relationship in a
lot of ways
i really hope that you know there is a
season four that she doesn't have a
boyfriend
like i really really really hope that
she gets better at baking she kind of
you know maybe she makes some because
mae's obviously gone away maybe she
makes some new friends but i really eric
hopefully
but you know i don't want her to have a
boyfriend because i really do think it's
important that she doesn't for a while
what about
um for both of you guys more dale shut
down
maeve is off to the usa like you
mentioned what would you like to see in
season four in that regard do they all
find a different school to go to
does maeve come back what
in your minds
happens
yeah definitely hope maeve comes back
wc has to he has to she absolutely has
to that's too yeah um oh god what i hope
is such like
what do you because mortal is gone where
those literally gone like i don't know
i just hope that they all continue to
just like grow i hope they find a way to
just like hang out together i hope they
just
i don't know how we bring them together
maybe like
i don't know some sort of course
i have no idea but we need to see them
together again we need like the gang to
be about together again i think because
i wonder what's gonna happen to the
teachers miss sans and mr hendricks both
wanted to be her teacher that was going
to be such a that was an interesting
thing because it was like this couple
kind of like head-to-head for who's
going to be her teacher and then all of
a sudden it's gone would you guys want
to do a season
four if it's up to you yes
yeah yeah
right
i would like to watch it
yeah we've got more stories to tell
i am aware that you know
we are now a lot older than the
characters
you guys look so young it doesn't matter
yeah oh god let's just top up on the
skincare routine yeah we'll try we'll
try our best
[Music]